oh hi we here at game life hope you had
a great thanksgiving or if you don't
live in america a normal thursday black
Friday has now come and gone and
actually most of the years major video
games are now on shelves but thankfully
there are a few exceptions which is good
because this video with otherwise just
be three minutes of awkward silence the
big one is far cry 3 coming tuesday
december for critics have been raving
about this open-world shooter it's got a
compelling story with a lunatic
antagonist freeroaming gameplay that
lets you tackle problems any way you
want and a gorgeously rendered jungle to
play around in it's also got a
cooperative multiplayer mode that lets
for players team up for many missions
but the open-ended single-player
adventure is the star far cry 3 is out
for xbox 360 playstation 3 and pc if
you're a PlayStation 3 diehard you've
been waiting for this for a long time
Mass Effect trilogy released last month
on 360 and pc is now available on
December fourth for the ps3 this is
actually the first time that Sony gamers
have gotten to play the original Mass
Effect the game that started this sci-fi
space opera series at sixty dollars for
all three games Mass Effect trilogy is a
real bargain no matter what platform you
buy it on yet we would advocate more of
a wait and see approach to Marvel
Avengers battle for Earth this motion
controlled comic book brawler was
previously released on xbox kinect and
now it's available on the wii u the
kinect version didn't exactly thrill the
critics so it's unlikely the wii u
version is going to be that much better
but it does have is a couch potato mode
so you can make your friend grab the
wiimote and stand up and wave it all
around the room throwing lightning bolts
of Thor smashing in heads is Hulk and
all you have to do is just sit on the
couch and use the touchscreen and
fashion heads without even working up a
sweat
marvel avengers battle for Earth is
coming to wii u december four and that's
about it i mean i guess i can tell you
about cabela's dangerous hunts for Wii U
or rapala best pro fishing but I don't
think people who buy those games watch
videos about video games on the internet
so I'm done